impfungen haben sich von gerade
angesprochen nahezu alle zugesagten
versprechen zitat von ihnen können
derzeit leider nicht eingehalten werden
was ist denn da eigentlich tatsächlich
schief gelaufen
er ist eine spannende frage also die im
logistik steht eigentlich in deutschland
über die länder und kommunen
und was da ist ein impfstoff wird
verimpft es ist auch nicht alles perfekt
aber im grossen ganzen funktioniert ist
aber der impfstoff fehlt und erkennbarer
weise klappen verschiedene dinge nicht
offenkundig wurde zu wenig bestellt
deswegen war bisher auch
nachbestellungen offenkundig vielleicht
sogar das falsche wir haben jetzt gerade
über das beispiel astra zenica
gesprochen wo wir jetzt einfach mal
schauen müssen was das ergebnis ist dort
soll weniger geliefert werden und
möglicherweise müsste dann das weiß frau
professor muss dann besser
auch sogar die impfempfehlungen sich
ändern wenn man nur den impfstoff für
jüngere oder nicht für ältere verwenden
dürfte
und schauen sie im umgekehrten fall
heute kam die meldung bei pfizer
dort werden in den usa vor der zeit
geliefert und zehn prozent mehr also
insgesamt entsteht da wirklich kein
gutes bild und viele impfstoffhersteller
sagen dass auch sehr offen europa zu
spät bestellt und ist deswegen auch
später dran und es ist schon finde ich
eine echte herausforderung denn das
impfen entscheidet zum einen über
wirtschaftliche stärke genau der
professor vergib mir das sicherlich
recht wer schneller geimpft ist kann
schneller durchstarten ist natürlich die
rückgabe von freiheit und was für mich
das wichtigste
es rettet absolut leben und deswegen ist
die situation wirklich aus meiner sicht
deswegen schwierig weil wir gerade im
übergang sind in der gefahr
es geht drunter die zahlen die mutation
kommt umso wichtiger wäre jetzt ein ein
nachhaltiges impf und es ist tatsächlich
so in israel scheint es ja so zu sein
dass die impfungen sehr hoch sind und
junge leute geimpft werden und bei uns
warten viele risikogruppen und viele
ältere immer noch auf ihre impftermin in
einigen bundesländern haben wir sogar
ein impfstoff gehabt bayern jetzt nicht
aber ich verstehe es wenn der impfstoff
nicht da ist und das sind kann man nur
daran arbeiten so schleunigst und so
schnell wie möglich einfach die
lieferungen ein halten zu lassen
verlässliche planung zu haben für die
impfung vor ort und natürlich auch mehr
impfstoff zu produzieren ich hoffe das
kann bei besser wird
aber trotzdem noch mal konkret die frage
was ist da was schief gelaufen gelaufen
aus ihrer perspektive
oder anders gefragt wie hätten sie es
gemacht eine deutsche bestellung an der
europäische bestellung eine frühere
bestellung eine beherzte hre bestellung
die bereitschaft mehr geld in die hand
zu nehmen auch mit der gefahr dass man
möglicherweise die eine oder andere
milliarde schlicht und ergreifend
versenkt aber wissen dass man auf der
anderen seite sitzt hier fast
millionenbeträge mittlerweile einen tag
eine milliarde pro tag so verlieren wir
dafür berichten und da hat mir eine
menge impfstoff für gekriegt haben
eine professorin kollegin von ihnen ich
glaube aus mainz die sagte für zehn
milliarden hätten wir von allen
potenziellen kandidaten für die gesamte
eu so viel impfdosen rechtzeitig
bestellen können dass wir in jedem fall
auf der sicheren seite gewesen wären wie
hätten sie es gemacht also wie es
gemacht hätte das ist jetzt nicht mehr
als beckmesser risch von der seite sagen
was man besser gemacht hätte
aber das alles was sie gerade
zusammengetragen haben auch die stimmen
die ich jetzt gehört aber stimmen alle
ich habe nicht verstanden so wenn man
das so sieht das ist ja alles noch
relativ intransparent
die bestellung formen ist wirkt so als
hätte man ein klassisch europäisches
vergabe und bestellungsverfahren gemacht
das sehr knapp orientiert ist das eine
sehr harte preisliche komponente hat das
ist in normalen zeiten 1 1 ein sicheres
und gutes verfahren aber in notzeiten
wie wir schwierig mein eindruck ist auch
man hat vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr
auf einzelne impfstoffe gewettet quasi
gesetzt und andere nicht da hätte ich
einen breiteren ansatz gewählt ich hätte
in der tat wie die beiden professoren
andeuten lieber mehr bezahlt weil wenn
man auch mehr im stoff hätte hätte man
den übrigens genauso wenn man ihn nicht
braucht weitergeben können an andere
sogar dann umsonst und günstig
beispielsweise und die kosten sind
eindeutig evident während wesentlich
billiger gewesen ganz verstehe ich nicht
und wissen sie wo ich auch noch ein
bisschen zurückhaltend wenn ich bin
wirklich gegen einen solchen impfen
aktionismus wie er da die diskutiert
wird nur offenkundig würde einen anderen
ländern wird da weniger ethisch
argumentiert sondern sehr praktisch und
malsfeld scheint aufzufallen das in 4
der ländern dortige regionale farmer
kapazitäten komplett umgestellt oder
genutzt werden um impfstoff zu
produzieren
und da glaube ich wir haben jetzt in
marburg die hoffnung auf ein
zusätzliches werk da will ich noch mal
dass wir in europa einfach nochmal jetzt
mehr liefern können
wir sind doch ein kontinent mit
pharmaunternehmen mit konzernen mit
hoher leistungsdichte
es müsste doch möglich sein in kürzerer
zeit diese produktion des impfstoffes
auch an anderen kapazitäten zu schaffen
kann da nur appellieren daran
ich will ja keinen kritisieren weil es
klingt dann auch das so man macht sich
dann schlanken fuß aber ich weiß im
eines die enttäuschungen vor ort sind
echt groß und und es tut ihm auch ein
bisschen in der seele weh wenn ich das
sein darf wenn leute impfen wollen auch
unter spezifische personal möchten und
es gibt auch viele menschen die geimpft
werden wollen
aber sie warten können wir darauf war
sie in andere länder und sagen na
schauen in andere länder und sagen warum
geht es dann da und da glaube ich haben
wir einfach müssen wir einfach besser
werden doch mal was wo ist aus ihrer
sicht ja der entscheidende fehler
passiert in berlin oder in brüssel
ist das jetzt hilfreich über viele
regierung bringt weiter ich finde schon
finden sie nicht frau hungers eigentlich
nicht weil das nützt uns jetzt überhaupt
nichts mehr zu überlegen werden fehler
gemacht hat man muss ja jetzt überlegen
wie es weitergehen kann
ich bin dezidiert anderer meinung wie
sehen sie das denn persönlich also lernt
man aus fehlern viele suchen sich je
nach suche also muss auf 1 aufpassen auf
1 aufpassen
natürlich wird es wird das auch in
deutschland unterschiedlich
interpretiert und da gibt es neben den
ehrbaren motive für mehr impfstoff
natürlich auch den einander mit der
taktischen motiv das in ordnung so ist
auch die öffentliche diskussion es geht
auch um eine ganze menge genau die
fehleranalyse macht deswegen sinn
überhaupt zu erkennen was los ist ein
beispiel
es entsteht der eindruck und ich weiß
nicht ob es ob es weise aber es heißt es
dass möglicherweise sogar impfstoff der
in europa produziert würde dann
ausgeführt wird bis ein gerüchte in den
medien ich kann es nicht belegen
und jetzt scheint so zu sein dass die eu
in ihren verträgen gibt es da regelungen
das zu verhindern oder nicht und
insofern ist das schon zum beispiel so
eine ganz spannende frage werden
vertrag gemacht wie sieht er aus kann
man möglicherweise auch mit ganz
seriösen normal üblichen
vertragskonditionen argumentieren oder
ist vielleicht was vergessen worden und
das macht es dann schwieriger da eine
lösung herbeizuführen muss noch einmal
den tatbestand kennen
frau professor muss und dann die
schwächen auszugleichen die wir haben
wir sind uns in der analyse einig es
geht nicht darum jemand irgendwo
anzuklagen ja sondern umgekehrt einfach
zu sagen wie kann man es besser machen
wir können wir zusammen helfen ja also
die die fehleranalyse finde ich es schon
wichtig weiß irgendwann mal auch um
schlicht und ergreifend um politische
verantwortung geht also ich hab da viele
fragen hat wenn wir mal nicht gerade
ich habe sehr viele fragen im kopf auch
zum beispiel ein kleines detail von
meiner seite ich weiß daß die/der der
vertrag mit moderner zum beispiel der
amerikanischen firma im august zu ende
verhandelt war unterschrieben wurde das
ding dann irgendwann ende november
anfang dezember wie kann das sein
was ist in der zwischenzeit passiert das
sind zum beispiel so fragen die ich
schlicht und ergreifend nicht
nachvollziehen kann
also wir sind alles fragen die finde ich
sind gerechtfertigt es geht ja noch viel
weiter ich sage ihnen ein anderes
beispiel jetzt hat wir kommen in europa
plötzlich ich weiß nicht wie es vom
frühsommer sieht auch eine andere
komische situation
ungarn wieder einmal ungarn lässt sich
jetzt russischen impfstoff liefern und
wird ihn wohl eigenständig zu lassen was
eigentlich in europa gar nicht geht
es gibt den chinesischen impfstoffe
gehen wir jetzt eigentlich mit diesen
dingen um funktionieren die wissen wir
bis sie diese impfstoffe sicher ich kann
es von hier aus nicht beurteilen dafür
fehlt die kompetenz das muss europa und
im zweifel zwar natürlich die
bundesbehörde entscheiden aber da gibt
es leider so fragen ja oder noch eine
zusatzfrage wo ich sehr hoffe dass wir
vielleicht eine lösung finden
wir haben neben dem impfen wurde jetzt
ja auch gesagt es gebe neue beste
medikamente knapp
china run heißt dieses medikament das
das haben wir aber einen donald trump
wohl erlebt haben gelernt dass
offenkundig wirkt da wird gesagt es
könnte uns sehr helfen ist aber nur in
kleinen mengen da nur wenig zugelassen
auch da wird schon wieder an vielleicht
eine erwartung geweckt die wir nicht
erfüllen könnten
hoffe ich einfach sehr dass wir
erwartungsmanagement und liefern an
themen dass wir das noch besser
synchronisieren weil
die haben nämlich tatsächlich menschen
rufen dann an bei den hotlines fragen
was ist da los warum geht das nicht und
das ist dann auch für die kommunen und
die kommunalen impfzentren mama ganz
schwer da eine antwort zu geben und wie
fühlen sich dann auch einfach unter
druck darum möchte ich das nicht
weitergeben als druck aber einfach noch
mal bitten auch dass wir in deutschland
und das habe ich ja nein oder die
kanzlerin voran vor allen dingen machte
auch druck und und darf wenn ich das so
sagen darf unter endlich mehr impfstoff
zu bekommen aber daran hängt nicht
wirklich viel nämlich wie wir am ende
aus krone heraus kommen und wie wir
wieder neu starten können in genau im
interesse von mansfelder professor
felber mal auch wirtschaftlich in
konkurrenz verhältnis zu amerika und
china genauso glauben sie wer mich alles
an ruft genau weil weil die leute an
reiche leute einfach wissen wann sie
dran sind dann werden mir
krankengeschichten geschildert
geschildert wie gefährlich die arbeit in
der örtlichen praxis im krankenhaus ist
ganz überwiegend wirklich
nachvollziehbar und zurecht menschen der
höchsten prioritätsstufe die sagt aber
warum kriegen wir der nichts und dann
kann ich aus der sicht des zentrums in
götting ebenso sagen wir haben nichts
wir warten auf impfstoff wir wissen im
moment nicht sicher wann wir die nächste
lieferung bekommen
das kann noch einige wochen dauern er
selber mal auch der eindruck der der
öffentlichkeit entsteht also das
sozusagen anonymen immer aber schon
harter tobak pharmamanager plötzlich
drohen und sagen also wenn ihr
möglicherweise irgendwelche
exportbestimmungen an lasst dann werden
wir dafür sorgen dass sie einfach gar
nichts mehr kriegt dann hören wir
einfach auf mit der produktion von
impfstoff das ist ja ein ganz neuer
sound und ich muss ehrlich sagen auch so
würdelos was da passiert wenn man sich
mal anschaut dass wir hier von der
menschheitsaufgabe stehen das ist doch
wahnsinn ja ich glaube das kann man sich
politisch nicht gefallen lassen auch vor
dem hintergrund dass ja sehr viel geld
in die hand genommen wurde um die
forschenden pharma und industrien zu
unterstützen 750 millionen euro für die
impfstoffforschung allein in deutschland
dann hat deutschland noch eine viertel
milliarde glaube ich gegeben im
internationalen kontext wir haben den
unternehmen bezuschusst der kredite
gegeben
also da ist viel geld in die forschung
geflossen und das ist noch dort doppelt
unverständlich dass man erst dass das
land das so wehgetan hat für die
erforschung jetzt hinter sich hinten
anstellen muss
so unverständlicher dass dann dieses
land auch nicht wie es früher bestellt
hat wenn man das alles muss an so viel
geld darin investiert hat warum warum
hat man dann nicht das vertrauen so
sagen ja wir vertrauen auf unseren
hersteller auf bayern tag und wir kaufen
denen so viele babys gibt ja mehrere man
wusste halt nicht vorher welcher es wird
und fröhlich und das ganze land hinein
sagen wer hätten hätten wir besser
anders gemacht vermutlich wäre das
geschrei auch groß gewesen wenn sehr
viel geld eben in impfstoffe investieren
wäre dein nächster zulassung kommen
das stimmt aber jetzt wissen wir es und
jetzt erst ist fast jedes summe jede
beliebige summe die zu mehr impfstoff
führt gut ausgegeben
wenn wir uns vor augen führen was die
krise jeden tag kostet da können wir
fast eine beliebige summe haben dass wir
daraus gelernt habe also wenn es eine
milliarde pro tag kostet und wir für
zehn milliarden ausreichend impfstoff
von allen namhaften herstellern hätten
bestellen können dann wenn man es doch
nur mal raus herr söder wir haben
gestern interessante frage die er gerade
wieder touchieren nämlich die frage nach
den nach den hilfen sozusagen die es
gegeben hat für montag und andere auch
für cure weg beispielsweise viele viele
hundert milliarden zur erforschung
dieser impfstoff um das ganze wirklich
zu beschleunigen und auch sicher zu
machen im übrigen das kann man nicht oft
genug sagen
man sagt da viele unsicherheiten gibt
die frage nach dem generika
beispielsweise müsste da die politik
möglicherweise an greifen und sagen
freunde dem schieben jetzt einen riegel
vor ihr sagt uns jetzt bitte wie wir das
am besten bauen und dann können das auch
andere aber wir machen das jetzt und
zwar einfach deswegen weil jetzt an
diesem punkt in unserer geschichte es
eben um eine menschheitsaufgabe geht und
nicht mehr darum sozusagen den
kapitalismus am laufen zu halten um es
mal ganz platt zu sagen
also wir bekennen uns zu eigentum und
auch zu dem jahr zudem eigentum auf
geist jahres eigentlich keine frage
schon wichtig aber in einem bin ich
schon überzeugt ich bin schon überzeugt
dass das jetzt eine einmalige situation
ist und auch eine notsituation ja und
ich glaube schon dass wir uns überlegen
müssen alle kapazitäten und rechtlichen
möglichkeiten zu nutzen um in
vernünftiger form genau das zu erzielen
was vorhin jetzt schon mehrfach
angesprochen wurde
ausreichende und planbare
impfstoffversorgung allein der hinweis
auf ende sommer macht die leute jetzt
eher unsicher und er noch sogar sehr
pessimistisch vor allem wenn wir dann
die bilder von woanders sieht wir sind
ich bin kein impfstoff hat dann sagen
die leute erhalten durch da warten
darauf aber wenn du dann siehst dass er
bei nachbarn und befreundeten
partnerländern das anders ist und dann
wird ist schon dann wird es schon schwer
bis ich sie auch bilder aus den usa habe
ich im internet bilder gesehen lehrer
die sagen jetzt geht es bald mit der
schule wieder los jugendliche werden nur
anders geht das übrigens auch noch ein
echtes thema ist warum den jungen
menschen mehr perspektiven da gibt es so
viele möglichkeiten wenn sie das sehen
wir in china auch gearbeitet wird
natürlich mit anderen methoden aber die
effizienz ist an einigen stellen
zumindest im ergebnis erkennbar ist nur
noch mal ein dringender rat und ich
denke da brauchen wir auch noch mal die
debatte was was haben wir für rechtliche
möglichkeiten aus unseren bisherigen
verträgen und zweitens was können wir
zusätzlich akquirieren
ich höre dass in frankreich so was
überlegt wird wir sollten in deutschland
das auch machen
es geht nicht und es ist mir ein
wichtiges anliegen weil das wird dann
immer so zitiert man würde jetzt dagegen
diesen oder jenen politiker der
politikerin agierende stimmt nicht es
gibt sich jeder mühe und jeder kämpft
wirklich und an diesen fronten jeden tag
nur die ergebnisse einfach die müssen in
diesem prozess einfach besser werden und
zwar schnell
darf ich da wieder trotzdem noch mal
nachfragen was steht denn da konkret vor
also das wäre ja ganz entscheidender
neuer schritt dass wir eine neue
weichenstellung sie sagen da müssen wir
staatlicherseits eingreifen was könnten
sie sich vorstellen
ich will da nichts vorgeben ich glaube
nur einfach dass man nochmal über alle
möglichkeiten die gesetzgeberisch sind
in frankreich würde ich wird es gemacht
noch mal nachdenken ob wir zusätzliche
produktion schaffen oder auch
beispielsweise wenn wir über kosten
reden
es deutet sich an in indien heißt es so
in die bisher die heutige eigentlich die
große apotheke.de waren das früher in
deutschland allein das wird ja alles
andere an arzneimitteln produziert dort
lesen wir und hören wir dass sozusagen
das land selber die unternehmen bietet
mehr oder minder höflich sozusagen ihre
produktion
an einigen stellen zu drosseln um
impfstoff zu produzieren übrigens mit
dem ergebnis was wir erleben werden das
dann auch die medizinische versorgung
für andere medikamente im jahr über
anders werden könnte wir haben das
letzte jahr früher ein bisschen schon
erlebt und das sind alles um momente wo
ich sage können wir nicht auch
produktionen stärker umstellen darauf
ausrichten auch mit finanziellen
ausgleich also man professor felbermayr
so anzuknüpfen dann lieber geld dafür
geben den unternehmen genau und dafür
eben schnell durch arbeiten und durch im
fall khedira wirklich dafür
mir ist da noch ein bisschen da ist
glaube ich noch ein bisschen fantasie
möglich um da zu agiert das
hochspannende punkte eher wenig
diskutiert ich gebe die frage gerne
direkt an den ökonomen erst mal weiter
also was ist rechtlich möglich was ist
wirtschaftlich möglich was können wir da
an den punkt wir müssen den produzierten
unternehmen auch einmal die anreize
wirklich geben selber alles zu tun um
die produktionskapazitäten aus zu denen
wir haben glaube ich gut geschafft die
anreize zu setzen das gut geforscht wird
schnell geforscht wird auch schneller
als findet es sich eigentlich gedacht
haben aber die anreize zu investieren
möchten wir sie dann die
produktionskapazitäten ja nur kurz aus
zu lassen denn wenn die bevölkerung
durch geimpft ist hat man dann die die
werke stehen und braucht sie nicht mehr
da muss der staat eingreifen das lässt
auch nicht am markt übrigens das sind
auch die meisten ökonomen einig und
brauchen auch gar nicht über sozusagen
eingriff in eigentumsrechte man kann
damit geld sehr viel richten was
rechtlich geht zum beispiel wäre in der
tat exportgenehmigungen nachzufragen das
ist nicht passiert dass die impfstoffe
die mit deutschen steuergeldern hier
erforscht wurden und hier auch
produziert wurden dass die dann europa
verlassen da jedenfalls exportkontrolle
das heißt nicht exportverbote aber dass
man jedenfalls zunächst einmal
transparenz hat darüber was da vorgeht
fragen was sie wollten gerade ich finde
die idee dass man ja
produktionskapazitäten nutzt wo sie da
sind erst mal charmant
es bietet aus meiner sicht zwei
schwierigkeiten zum einen habe ich mal
von einem stiko kollegen gelernt dass
der eigentliche flaschenhals nicht die
produktion der impfstoffe sondern die
abfüll kapazitäten sind und das ist
etwas was man jetzt auch nicht in der
örtlichen brauerei statt bierflaschen
machen kann sondern was
auch einen erheblichen technischen und
ja auch zertifizierungs vorlauf hat aber
das ist sicher etwas was man damit
denken sollte und das andere
meines wissens hatte anfang des jahres
auf der ganzen welt jede firma die
irgendwie impfstoff kann einen
potenziellen cupid impfstoff in der
pipeline
da sind einige von inzwischen die nicht
mehr verfolgt werden
da kann man sicherlich dann sagen man
stellt um bei anderen würde es
möglicherweise bedeuten dass man die
weiterentwicklung vorhandener kandidaten
auf diese art und weise abstellt ich
habe heute irgendwo gelesen glaube es
war spiegel online ganz sicher bin ich
nicht dass ich glaube sanofi angeboten
hat jetzt eben bei und impfstoff zu
produzieren nachdem der eine super sache
und das wird sich auch nicht zu deren
schaden sein
aber die frage ist eben ob man anderswo
impfstoffe die in der entwicklung
fortgeschritten sind stoppen soll und
sagen sollen er jetzt machen sie wieder
was anderes zumal das ja doch eine
längerfristige umstellung ist das sind
komplizierte substanzen grade dm rna
impfstoffe die in der herstellung eben
auch nicht einfach sind bei anderen
impfstoffen mag das anders sein oder ist
das auch anders die sind aber zum teil
noch nicht ganz so weit in der
entwicklung oder zulassung und manche
möchte man vielleicht auch hier nicht
unbedingt haben weil man sich ein
bisschen welche die chinesische
entspricht im moment sicher nicht oder
erfüllt nicht die kriterien die in
europa für eine zulassung erforderlich
wären
und persönlich ist mir ganz lieb dass
die die wir haben dann auch das
zulassungsverfahren ordentliche erfüllt
der sekretärin der unterschiedlich ist
sie sagen nein ich würde von kollegen
und kolleginnen von ihnen die sagen
dieser russische impfstoff ich muss ich
mich kurz und ich weiß es tatsächlich
nicht im detail okay aber es wäre zu
prüfen
und ich würde wäre es sehr unsympathisch
wenn nichts gesagt wurde na ja wir
nehmen jetzt den russischen ohne dass
der das ganz normale zulassungsverfahren
der e mail die ja auch kein notfall
verfahren in dem sinn erkennt wie das in
anderen ländern zum teil gemacht wurde
dass darauf plötzlich verzichtet wird
wir reden gleich nochmal ausführlich
auch über astra zeneca in dem
zusammenhang weil gerade gesagt wurde da
gibt es andere impfstoff für die auch
durchaus probleme machen
der macht auch probleme das ist aber die
entscheidung der patron helber bitte
deshalb guter skater okay gut
herstellbar oder nicht richtig
funktioniert hilft uns das auch nicht
weiter
herr söder sie sprachen gerade andere
länder an auch um uns herum
wie finden sie das was israel da gerade
macht die sind mittlerweile fast bei der
quote von 50 prozent
beeindruckend natürlich gerne bieres und
freundin zu israel israel ist auch sehr
gebeutelt worden von corona den letzten
monaten wirklich stark und schwer
hab immer herausforderung corona gehabt
ich ich persönlich leidet ist nicht im
gegenteil ich freue mich darüber wenn es
anderen wenn es bei anderen gut gelingt
mir wäre es noch lieber als würde bei
uns gemeinsam gut gelingen so würde ich
mal sagen und wir merken jetzt auch
schon in unserer diskussion werden uns
hier leider echt hochkarätige experten
in der runde muss man wirklich sagen ein
bisschen stochern wir alle im nebel was
ist möglich also wir bewegen genau die
fragen wie eigentlich viele andere auch
bewegen müssten
man muss aus diesem aus diesem
sammelsurium an guten ideen jetzt auch
ein politisches und auch ein
wirtschaftlich und technologisches
konzept werden weil frau professor ist
das ansporn natürlich muss ein
zulassungsverfahren absolut sicher sein
denn wir spüren dass die
impfbereitschaft auch so eine
zweigeteilte sarah ist ja wir haben
viele die sich impfen lassen möchten und
wir haben auch viele die nach wie vor
sehr skeptisch sind deswegen sollte man
da keine fehler machen und deswegen
teile ich das absolut was sie zum
zulassungsverfahren gesagt manchmal
kommt einem da auch so ein gefühl wenn
die gleichen stoffe woanders auch
zugelassen nur viel schneller
dann denkt man ob nicht auch bei uns
aber an einigen stellen die verfahren
noch ein bisschen optimiert werden
könnten aber das ist auch nur eine ein
eindruck der der des o2 herrscht bei den
russischen und chinesischen impfstoff
teile ich die skepsis die gesagt diese
gesagt haben eine frau klaus bevor wir
gleich nach israel gehen bei markus ja
gerade von fehlern gesprochen hatte
wollte ich noch geschwind einwerfen dass
ich schon in sehr großen fehler von ihm
fand damals als er vorgeschlagen hat
pflegekräfte hätten doch die
bürgerpflicht sich zu impfen oder man
ein bisschen diskutieren ob es da nicht
eine pflicht geben sollte
das kann man diskutieren aber es war
wirklich in dem moment zu dem zeitpunkt
so kontraproduktiv was
uns einmal kurz vor dem thema bleiben
ich sehe was die schwer und tief atmet
ich finde das zynisch in einem moment wo
alle die auch alle die pflegekräfte und
die ärzte und sie die sich gerne impfen
lassen möchten keine möglichkeit dazu
bekommen und dann finde ich diese
diskussion überhaupt nicht hilfreich
zumal wir hier nirgendwo evidenz dafür
haben dass eine impfpflicht etwas nützt
und ja es vielleicht auch den einen oder
anderen grund gibt warum ausgerechnet
pflegekräfte gerade nicht so viel
vertrauen in das politische zwangs
diskussionen haben sag ich da ist viel
schief gegangen am anfang da gab es
keine masken später gab es keine tests
als die im fußball schon gab und dann
heißt es aber jetzt müssen sie und was
kriegen sie davon wenn sie glück haben
ein bisschen beifall also da hat eben
auch viel nicht funktioniert und da
finde ich diese diskussion eben
überhaupt nicht hilfreich im moment
seien heftige heftige eruption hergé
dabei eben thema wie haben sie es denn
tatsächlich gemeint ich hatte um da
jetzt noch mal nicht jetzt öl ins feuer
zu gießen aber sozusagen noch mal eine
perspektive einfach zu bieten ich hatte
auch das gefühl das ist eine
phantomdiskussion weil wir reden über
das was ja gar nicht geht
also wir können ja gerne sagen
pflegekräfte müssen sich impfen können
wir lange darüber streiten ob man das so
machen sollte aber der ganz andere punkt
ist doch es ist noch gar nicht
praktikabel also wenn du gar kein
impfstoff hast braucht man da so was gar
nicht in der 100 zu werden
nein das ist nicht richtig und auch die
wortwahl die genannt wurde mit zynisch
finde ich auch nicht angemessen also
erstmal es werden alten und pflegeheime
prioritär geimpft
in bayern jetzt sind weit über 80
prozent in der altenpflege heime bereits
in der ersten impfung durch das heißt es
wird dort geimpft und wir stellen fest
dass es bei den bewohnern eine sehr hohe
impfbereitschaft gibt aber beim personal
eine deutlich geringere es ist fakt also
und wir b2d fakt ist eindeutig dass es
so ist dass dort die größte
herausforderung für leib und leben
besteht
drittens ist es so der ethikrat selbst
hat gesagt dass er sich dass für
bestimmte gruppen in einer solchen
situation dass mir das überlegen kann es
ist also irgendwie frau klaus meinte
jetzt also eine meinung einfach so
sondern es ist auch eine ethisch
fundierte position
ich habe gefragt wie die debatte weiter
geht drüber und eines muss ich schon
aussagen wir haben bei maß an eine
impfpflicht bei maß an eine impfpflicht
sehr umstritten und die begrüße ich habe
ich damals auch unterstützt gibt es gute
gründe habe aber wir haben sie ja ich
glaube das kann man sagen
es gab eine mehrheit dafür und jetzt
finde ich das maß an sehr gefährlich
sind corona aber auch und das ist glaube
ich nicht böse oder zynisch oder
ähnliches wenn wir einfach in einer
solchen phase wo wir sind meine
überlegung gehabt haben es muss nicht
sein
wir waren am ende die ergebnisse
gemeinsam bewerten aber eine debatte die
der ethikrat selber führt die ist nicht
etwa nur aus der luft gegriffen und
deswegen glaube ich einfach dass man da
ich stimme dem zu dass man für
pflegekräfte seit dem jahr mehr tun muss
wir haben übrigens mehr bezahlt der
pflege bonus in bayern als der bund
deutlich mehr
wir machen auch mehr für die
pflegekräfte das ist alles richtig aber
die alten und pflegeheime sind unsere
achillesferse
und deswegen muss man da besonders am
auch sich darum kümmern das heißt sie
bleiben sozusagen bei dieser forderung
und sagen pflegekräfte sollten sich
impfen lassen müssen können die ethische
diskussion dazu sagt wie es ist wenn die
forderung ist sondern noch mal ja sicher
den impfstoff für die pflegekräfte gibt
es tschuldigung ja es ist inkorrekt also
das ist jetzt nicht gerade deswegen
frage ich noch sagen dafür gäbe es kein
impfstoff für alle anderen bereiche
haben sie völlig recht aber an der
stelle stimmt es nicht weil die
altenpflegeheime werden gerade kämpft
aber ich habe gesagt der ethik rat
sollte sich damit beschäftigen das war
meine position
mehr nicht also ja ja so dass geheime
werden gerade geimpft übrigens auch in
niedersachsen da sind wir auch relativ
weit gekommen auch in dem kol spot in
dem ich erlebe aber für die
krankenhäuser reicht es noch bei weitem
nicht die haben noch nicht mehr mit
ihrer hoch risikobereiche durch impfen
können im moment an dem punkt an ein
kurzer break so zu sagen wir hätten die
chance wieder wenn sie nicht weg müssen
wenn sie lust haben noch mit uns kurz
nach israel zu gehen wäre möglich aber
als interessant für sie oder drängt der
nächste termin ein bisschen so ich muss
noch einiges machen genau bei den themen
lokal ebenfalls auf arm aber ich
bis nach selber dass ich ein großer fan
solcher debatten bin und wir müssen auch
noch mehr über das ganze thema reden
weil ich der festen überzeugung bin dass
wir corona zwar überwinden werden aber
das ist noch ein spannender und auch
noch ein weg wird der uns alle sehr sehr
fordern und sehr fördern also danke ich
ihnen an diesem zeitpunkt wir sehen uns
und hören uns bei gelegenheit dann
wieder